WE HAVE AIRLINES THAT ARE NOW IN
GOOD SHAPE, THEY WILL PICK UP
WITH THE FARES AND SEATS, BUT
THE INDUSTRY IS IN GOOD SHAPE.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SAVE THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY, WHICH WOULD
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING IF THAT
HAPPENED.
THEY ARE IN GOOD SHAPE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, IF YOU EVER
WANTED TO BE A FLY ON THE WALL
IN THE CABINET ROOM OF THE WHITE
HOUSE, YOU JUST GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN IN ON A
CONVERSATION THE PRESIDENT WAS
HAVING WITH A COUPLE OF
GOVERNORS AND OF COURSE THE
SECRETARY INTERIOR DAVE
BARNHARDT, TAKING QUESTIONS FROM
THE PRESS.
WE HAVE "THE FIVE" TOGETHER.
TAKE IT AROUND THE TABLE, SO TO
SPEAK.
JESSE, LET’S START ON BIGGER
NEWS OF TODAY ON THE FLYNN
UNMASKING LIST THAT HAS COME
OUT.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT
THAT, HE HAS AN INTERVIEW WITH
MARIA BARTIROMO, WHICH WILL AIR
TOMORROW MORNING.
HE SAYS THERE IS MORE TO COME.
>> Jesse: WELL, THERE KEEPS
BEING MORE TO COME, HE’S BEEN
RIGHT.
FOX HAS BEEN RIGHT.
ALL OF OUR REPORTING ON THIS
ENTIRE THING HAS PROVEN TO BE
ACCURATE AND ALL REPORTING FROM
THE OTHER SIDE IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA HAS PROVEN FALSE, WHICH
MAKES ME WONDER, WHY AREN’T THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA REPORTERS
ANGRY?
THEY WERE FED LIES BY THEIR
SOURCES FOR THREE YEARS AND THEY
PRINTED FAKE NEWS.
IF I PRINTED FAKE NEWS FOR THREE
YEARS AND THEN I FOUND OUTTHROUG
TRANSCRIPTS MY SOURCES KNEW THEY
WERE TELLING ME LIES AND KNEW
THEY WERE HAVING ME PUSH A FAKE
STORY, I’D BE ANGRY AT MY
SOURCES.
BUT THEY’RE NOT ANGRY AT THEIR
THEY ARE ANGRY AT THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE POINTED OUT THAT THEIR
SOURCES LIED.
THINK ABOUT HOW RIDICULOUS THAT
IS.
NOW THEY’RE SAYING THE PRESIDENT
IS POLITICIZING THE
INTELLIGENCE.
THAT IS PRETTY FUNNY COMING FROM
THEM BECAUSE IT WASN’T DONALD
TRUMP THAT SET PEOPLE UP WITH
STINGS, THAT USED SPIES, THAT
COOKED UP CROOKED DOSSIERS AND
COLLUDED WITH THE RUSSIANS AND
ENTRAPPED PEOPLE AND THREW
POLITICAL OPPONENTS IN JAIL, NO,
THAT WAS DEMOCRATS THAT DID
THAT.
ALL THE PRESIDENT IS DOING NOW,
LIKE THIS UNMASKING LIST, IS
SHINING A LIGHT, ALL HE’S DOING
IS DISINFECTING THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
HE’S EXPOSING IT.
HE’S CORRECTING AN INJUSTICE,
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
THE TIMING IS NOT BEING USED TO
DISTRACT FROM THE PANDEMIC, IT
WAS ADAM SCHIFF THAT RELEASED
ALL OF THOSE TRANSCRIPTS UNDER
OATH.
REMEMBER THAT.
IT WAS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
THAT WITHHELD EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE FROM GENERAL FLYNN FOR
TWO YEARS.
TIMING OF THIS IS ON DEMOCRATS,
NOT ON THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Dana: UH-HUH.
GREG, JESSE BRINGS UP SOMETHING
THAT REMINDS ME OF, DO YOU
REMEMBER DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WHEN BEN RHODES
SAID, DID THAT INTERVIEW
BASICALLY SAYING HE HAD PLAYED
THE MEDIA ON IRAN?
AND HOW THEY FELL FOR EVERYTHING
THAT HE SAID?
I MEAN, WHEN JESSE SAID THAT, IT
MAEDZ
MADE HE THINK REPORTERS WOULD
HAVE BEEN MAD THEN.
>> Greg: YEAH.
I FEEL LIKE A BROKEN RECORD, THE
FACT IS, LOOK, I JUST SAW ONE OF
BIDEN’S SPOKESPERSON MELT DOWN
ON TWITTER OVER THIS, BASICALLY
ATTACKS CATHERINE HERRIDGE,
PRETTY BRUTAL ATTACK ON HER.
I BELIEVE THEY MIGHT HAVE
REMOVED THE TWEET.
I’M INTERESTED HOW THE MEDIA
WILL APPROACH THAT, WILL THAT BE
CONSIDERED SEXIST ATTACK BECAUSE
SHE’S A WOMAN OR IS IT DIFFERENT
BECAUSE IT WAS A DEMOCRAT DOING
THE ATTACKING?
IT IS CLEAR JOE’S CAMPAIGN IS
WORRIED.
I HATE TO ACT LIKE THE WORST,
THE VERY WORST OF THE MEDIA AND
WORST OF THE DEMOCRAT ABOUT
DEMANDING THIS PERSON GET LOCKED
UP AND THIS PERSON BE TRIED AND
THIS PERSON GO AWAY, BUT
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE FOR
ADAM SCHIFF BECAUSE HE CREATED
THREE YEARS OF MASSIVE FALICY
THAT DID SO MUCH DAMAGE TO THIS
COUNTRY AND MADE US MISS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST PFRNT
IMPORTANT STORIES OF OUR
LIFETIME, HAVING HEARINGS ON
IMPEACHMENT WHILE CORONAVIRUS
WAS EXPLODING, WE TALKED ABOUT
THE VIRUS IN GREEN ROOMS, BUT WE
HAD TO DO THE IMPEACHMENT STORY
AND SHOW THE HEARINGS.
IT IS ALL ON HIM, MAN.
HE’S GOT TO GO.
THEY GOT TO INVESTIGATE HIM, GOT
TO HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE.
I WILL NOT SAY HE SHOULD GO TO
PRISON, BUT MY EVIL TWIN WILL
SAY HE SHOULD GO TO PRISON FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
>> Dana: JUAN, THE NEXT FEW DAYS
WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
MANY DEMOCRATS WILL BE WILLING
TO TALK ON THE RECORD ABOUT WHAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON AND WHAT HAS
BEEN REVEALED.
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE ARE GLAD
TO TALK, THE QUESTION IS, ARE
YOU PLAYING INTO A POLITICAL
ACTION, YOU KNOW, REGARDLESS OF
HOW YOU VIEW IT, LOTS OF PEOPLE
WORRY IT IS DIVERSIONARY.
CERTAINLY VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS SAID THAT.
I WANT TO MENTION, DANA, I THINK
THE PRESIDENT WAS PRETTY CLEAR,
HE SAID THAT THE DEMOCRATS’ BILL
THAT NANCY PELOSI PUT OUT TODAY
IS DOA, DEAD ON ARRIVAL AND THEN
HE SAID THAT POWELL, FEDERAL
RESERVE CHAIR IS HIS MOST
IMPROVED PLAYER OVER LAST FEW
MONTHS FOR REDUCING INTEREST
RATES AND THE LIKE.
TODAY POWELL SAID THE ECONOMY IS
IN BIG TROUBLE AND NEEDS
ADDITIONAL HELP AND SUPPORT FROM
THE GOVERNMENT.
SO THE QUESTION NOW BECOMES,
WHAT WILL THE PRESIDENT AND THE
TREASURY SECRETARY, MR. MNUCHIN
PUT FORWARD?
ARE THEY GOING TO NEGOTIATE?
BECAUSE THEIR OWN FEDERAL
RESERVE CHAIR, THE MOST IMPROVED
PLAYER FOR THE PRESIDENT, IS
SAYING, THE ECONOMY, THE WORKERS
NEED HELP AND NANCY PELOSI IS
TALKING ABOUT GETTING MORE MONEY
TO WORKERS, MORE MONEY FOR
PEOPLE HUNGRY THROUGH FOOD
STAMPS, MORE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
>> Dana: ALSO HAVING GOVERNMENT
PLAY GOD IS NOT THE BEST WAY TO
GET MONEY IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT TODAY,
HOPEFULLY WILL GET A CHANCE
TOMORROW.
EMILY, CAN I TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THE REOPENING.
THE TALKING TO THE GOVERNOR, ARE
YOU SEEING THAT OUT WHERE YOU
ARE, THE PARKS ARE REOPENING,
PEOPLE ARE FIGURING OUT A WAY TO
GET BACK TO BUSINESS?
YOU MENTIONED A POSSIBLE
REGISTRY AT RESTAURANTS?
SEATTLE?
>> EXACTLY, THE GOVERNOR
OUTLINED A PLAN FOR RESTAURANT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE DINE-IN
PEOPLE, FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
GO SIT INDOOR, THE RESTAURANTS
HAVE TO STIPULATE, GRIEVANCE,
THAT WILL PROVIDE NAMESS,
E-MAILS, ADDRESSES AND TELEPHONE
NUMBERS OF THE DINERS.
OF COURSE PEOPLE ARE REVOLTING,
REMAINING TO BE SEEN IF THAT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED, THE
GOVERNOR ARTICULATED, DANA, YOU
ASKED ABOUT CALIFORNIA, WHERE